hatte war damals lukas meine lieben
freunde ich habe james auf twitter
gefunden
und james ist kein normaler james und an
james hilft leuten dabei ihre bilder mit
photoshop zu bearbeiten jetzt zum
beispiel liebe will wir an ihn gefragt
ob er ihren ex aus dem fotohaus photo
shoppen kann hier seht ihr das foto
eingeblendet also die stehen da so armen
armen mit zum kleid und er das auch
getan als zu warten dass sie jetzt das
nächste witzige foto und zwar der mag
ihn gefragt hey kannst du irgendwas mit
meiner hand machen wenn der linke
anliegen ein bisschen komisch aus mach
das mal so dass ich ihn was halten würde
oder so und er hat einfach
die krawatte länger gemacht und die
caption ist auch stark seit mai beste
jockey topform kommen können hier fragt
ein mädel den lieben james ob er nicht
wie sie und ihren freund ein bisschen
näher zusammen machen könnte weil die
dame die das foto gemacht hat wo
unbedingt diesem baum in der mitte drauf
kriegen wollte warum auch immer
und das hat auch gemacht
hat' nämlich beide zusammen im gleichen
t shirt hier fragt katie ob james das
ganze nicht ein bisschen interessanter
gestalten könnte sie steht dann nämlich
einfach auf einer veranda im roten kleid
und
die zeit wenn sie in der skiarena wird
hier wird james von einem franzosen
gefragt ob er nicht in den hintergrund
bei diesem schönen urlaubsfoto mit dem
meer und dem himmel so ein bisschen
gewitter und blitz machen kann und das
tut er auch
allerdings wurden die beiden halt vom
blitz getroffen hier hat rebecca den
james angeschrieben und hat gesagt die
füße von meinem freund sehen wir diesen
strand foto in die vollen aus kannst du
nicht ein bisschen kleiner machen und er
macht im gegenzug die füße von der harry
becker einfach deutlich größer atmen das
sind schon quadrat lahcen isabella stört
es bei diesem foto dass ihre haare im
gesicht von ihrem freund hängen und
james hatten ganz einfach eine lösung
würde ich genauso posten das mädchen
dass james dieses fotos zugeschickt hat
meint dass sie ein bisschen klang sie
aussieht mit diesem komischen gedrängt
da vorne dran auch in diesem komischen
strohhalm und james macht das einfach so
als wenn es um gefallen
und ich schwöre euch ich glaube jeder
von euch der sich mit photoshop auskennt
weiß wie geisteskrank viel arbeit in
jedem einzelnen bild steckt chelsea hat
geheiratet und auf dem hochzeitsfoto was
wirklich so dass beschlüsse
hochzeitsfoto ist dass ich hier gesehen
habe steht sie auch noch hinter einer
stange also ich weiß nicht was ich die
person ich das foto gemacht hat dabei
gedacht hat allerdings will kann sie
natürlich dass die sterne weg kommt
deswegen lässt james
kastraten arien war in hamburg unterwegs
schreibt er mit dazu hier in meiner cd
und hat ein foto gemacht mit einer
statue die allerdings nackt war unter
die mutter von arian
ein bisschen gläubig und religiös ist
werde er das seiner mutter so nicht
zeigen deswegen hat er gesagt james
kannst du bitte das machen dass die
statue nicht mehr nackt ist sondern
vielleicht bisschen was anhalt oder so
und das hat er auch gemacht allerdings
ist adrian jetzt ja ich wollte hier ein
schönes homecoming foto machen und dafür
hat sich das medien ex tra in so einem
greenscreen studio gestellt so getan als
würde sie so einen grünen umhang umarmen
damit das heutige photoshop werden kann
zu dem baum und james
hat glaube ich die falsche
losgeschnitten bei diesem foto hier
stört es dass mädchen das keine masken
getragen werden kohler und so meinte sie
es macht vielleicht sinn dass wir beiden
masken tragen wenn draußen unterwegs
blabla zwar während der quarantänezeit
und james den masken verpasst ihr wird
james von der rockband namens formosa
angeschrieben und zwar sehen die sich
selbst irgendwie nicht so hart in diesem
foto und sie wollen so ein bisschen mehr
mittelmäßig locken
ich bin luca und war ein halbes jahr an
australische kein deutsch mehr auf jeden
fall wollen die bisschen mehr in so eine
richtung aussehen und metall ist für
james dann auch direkt das richtige
stichwort gewesen aber von der
ritterrüstung an tim hat sich hier auf
diesem foto schön schick gemacht wie ein
hemd angezogen sakko drüber gelegt und
gelächelt da sein hemd allerdings sehr
sehr grell ist hat er gesagt dass seine
ziele dementsprechend voll gelb wirken
und ob james das nicht verändern könnte
das hat er getan die
zähne hat den strahlen der gemacht
unseren hemd hatte einfach durch nichts
ersetzt hier beschwert sich eine person
darüber dass die sonne in ihrem gesicht
stand und james meinte einfach nur no
more than for you
ich weiß nicht wie man auf diese idee
kommen denkt man halt wenn man sein
bearbeitetes foto sieht dass er einfach
gegoogelt hat ja schneemann oder
irgendwie so allerdings
sehe er schon ich habe das jetzt mal
ganz leicht über blenden lassen dass er
wirklich dieses haupt foto von imedo
genommen hat also da steckt wirklich so
geisteskrank viel arbeit drin und die
möglichen leute ich habe letztens video
zu dieser fei sap gemacht wir denken
dass das voll schnell geht zur sache zu
bearbeiten so die face ist geisteskrank
was uns angetan kann sagen deine nase
wird tyler das macht ihn ein paar
sekunden aber das ist schwierig mit
photoshop und erst recht wenn es um so
was geht da meinte der typ nämlich mit
lukas ich will ein bisschen gefährlicher
aussehen und james hat ihm
sandalen ge photoshop tier hat schon
gesagt dass er ist nicht cool findet
dass die stadt im hintergrund nicht im
fokus ist aber natürlich logisch wenn
man ein foto macht das noch eine sache
richtig fokussiert werden kann deswegen
hat james die stadt dann fokussiert aber
james nicht mehr hier wo james von einer
frau kontaktiert die gesagt hatte james
im hintergrund sitzen typ kannst du dir
vielleicht ein bisschen glücklicher
aussehen machen und das hat er auch
getan
nämlich die gesichter einfache getauscht
thalia hat james dieses foto hier
geschickt und gesagt kannst du
vielleicht diese standard der ich mich
festhalten dieses gelände aus dem bild
heraus photoshop sie legen ein bisschen
ruhiger aus und james ist durch eine
gießkanne ersetzt
und sie gießt dem beton vor ihren füßen
dieses foto hier hat marie james
geschickt gesagt ey kannst du nicht im
hintergrund ein wasserfall machen und
alles vielleicht ein bisschen grüner
aber ist fotos wahrscheinlich im herbst
entstanden daran die blätter nicht so
richtig an den bäumen und james
brolin wasserfalls doch was grünes ins
bild gemacht sprüngli hat ihren
geburtstag gefeiert und ein foto von
sich machen lassen typisch girlie mit
zwei zahlen dementsprechend die als sie
geworden ist und sie war zu blöd
schreibt sie hier selbst die einst
richtig zu halten deswegen hat die
gefragte james kannst du das nicht
irgendwie fixen und james hat das getan
er hat nämlich eine 71 gemacht und sie
extrem alt
bearbeitet heiler beschwert sich hierbei
james dass ihr freund immer das gleiche
calvin klein t shirt trägt und ob er das
nicht irgendwie verändern könnte und das
hat er getan hat das shirt aufgerissen
und revealed dass der freund von tyler
anscheinend helfen kleinen tattoo sogar
auf der brust hat hier wird james von
einer familie kontaktiert mit der bitte
ihr weihnachts foto ausnahme in anderen
richtung zu machen weil das ein bisschen
zu weit von unten war und die sind nicht
so ganz zufrieden damit deswegen
ja sagt glaube ich schon alles in diesem
foto hier hat david den james
kontaktiert und gesagt hey das ist das
einzige foto was wir im urlaub gemacht
haben allerdings standard wälder
zwischen uns kannst du das so machen das
nur meine freunde und ich zu sehen sind
und das hat james und hier beim letzten
foto wo james vor anastasia kontaktiert
und 20 sagen ey kannst du bitte die
nüsse entfernen und auch das hat er
getan
denn der freund von der stasi hat jetzt
keine nüsse mehr an es hätte mich das
heutige jetzt allerdings auch beide
männer lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das kann einen daumen hoch
oder dem wieder moniert meinen kanal und
klickte auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere
videos auf einem kanal nicht verpassen
wollte jamie 03 10 ist
selbstverständlich oben in der
beschreibung verlinkt schaut dort gern
mal vorbei und ich
jetzt dieses video